[Música]
buenos días a todos vamos a pensar un
poco en cómo mejorar nuestras ciudades
cómo contribuir desde nuestro rol de
ciudadanos
estamos en un momento de la humanidad
donde las ciudades están liderando todo
el cambio en todo el desarrollo humano
al final de la primera guerra mundial se
acabaron los imperios al final de la
segunda guerra mundial tenemos que el
mundo está constituido por por países
y ahora señoras y señores podemos dar la
bienvenida a la era de las ciudades son
las ciudades las que están cambiando el
mundo la que están consumiendo la mayor
cantidad de energía también emitiendo
los gases de efecto invernadero son los
que generan la mayor cantidad de la
riqueza a nivel mundial son las ciudades
las que en un contexto de paz y un
contexto de estabilidad económica lidera
el mundo ya no necesitan a sus países
funcionan en bloques funcionan por las
distintas civilizaciones que tenemos en
la tierra y en esta idea las ciudades
están permanentemente compitiendo por el
talento por los 1.700 millones de
miserias que están ahí fuera decidiendo
cuál es la mejor ciudad para desarrollar
su potencial
estas ciudades a la vez estar
aliviándose con los objetivos de
desarrollo sostenible de naciones unidas
quién son los que embarcan sus
inversiones en nuevas tecnologías en el
entorno de smart cities the smart cities
bueno cómo podemos desde nuestro rol de
ciudadanos ayudar a la ciudad es ayudar
a nuestra ciudad a ser más humana a
conseguir esos objetivos voy a dedicar
los próximos minutos a hablar de los
cuatro retos más importantes donde los
ciudadanos podemos contribuir vamos a
hablar de cómo ayudar a combatir el
cambio climático ayudado a dejar de
canalizar nuestras ciudades voy a hablar
sobre cómo establecer pautas de
sostenibilidad tener entornos de
economía circular y para poder evitar
que nuestro planeta se agote
finalmente hablaré de cómo conectar con
la ciudad cómo desarrollar ese
sentimiento de pertenencia cómo
contribuir también no solamente con
impuestos al desarrollo de nuestra
ciudad y finalmente intentar hacer
desaparecer el mito de la internet
es algo muy importante muy beneficioso y
está aquí para ayudarnos
se hablaba antes estamos en un entorno
de máxima urgencia allí nos gusta ser
catastrofista pero está claro que
tenemos que todos hacer una actividad
colectiva y esto va a requerir un
esfuerzo único un esfuerzo que no se
había hecho antes desde la segunda
guerra mundial todo el planeta tribus y
colaborar en combatir el cambio
climático
aquí hay ahora mismo 414 lados y a los
411 414 partículas por millón de co2
pero el aire que estamos abriendo allí
pueden estar ayer en otro lugar donde el
monto puede estar en la antártida de
acuerdo la atmósfera es única ya no es
cuestión de mi casa mi ciudad es
cuestión del mundo completo no tenemos
un plan de no tenemos un planeta que
aunque podamos en modernos tenemos que
cuidar de que tenemos y en esta
situación como como veis
tenemos que movilizarlos y tenemos que
intentar ayudar a nuestra ciudad en esos
objetivos de descarbonización cómo
conseguirlo fijémonos en las tres se
hables por un lado reducir nuestro
consumo de elementos que van a producir
co2
utilizar energías renovables
aquí lo veis reemplazar nuestro consumo
energético por energías que sean
renovables que no produzcan co2
precisamente intentar ayudar a la ciudad
a eliminar co2 del ambiente la única
cosa que hay ahora mismo que secuestran
se reduce y fija ese frío del ambiente
es un árbol
vamos a intentar también contribuir a
plantar más árboles atraer más masa el
forestal se está hablando de edificios
hechos de madera que fijan esa madera en
un entorno que va a permanecer durante
muchos años y sobre todo intentemos no
quemar grasa e intentemos no producir
más
las ciudades se mueve el entorno de
intentar ser carbono neutral tener un
balance entre el cielo más que en los
procesos de gestión de la ciudad y en
0-2 que capturó por mis bosques y por
mis actividades no es suficiente hay que
ir a un entorno del carbón negative es
decir que absorba más del que invitó
neutraliza marea para ir reduciendo lo
que ya tenemos ahora mismo y nuestra
atmósfera los para mí es uno de los
problemas que más me preocupa porque
requiere una conciencia global y porque
los expertos tampoco se ponen de acuerdo
hay algunos que dicen que ya el mal es
irreversible está claro si llegamos a
esas concentraciones de 430 partículas
por millón la temperatura subirá en dos
grados y tendrá consecuencias realmente
catastróficas para nuestro planeta
esto pasó antes y pasó antes y ha pasado
antes como una extinción del 95% de la
población entonces vamos a por ello no
vamos a intentar mitigarlo un tema que
me preocupa es la cuestión ética y es
que las probablemente las ciudades en
eso
que más hemos contribuido a estos somos
los que menos vamos a sufre no van a ser
muchas otras poblaciones en países donde
va a subir el nivel del mar 5 metros
donde van a tener enormes sequías donde
van a sufrir
sobre todo en este cambios climáticos
vamos a pensar un poco cada día en cuál
es mi con solución en co2 en el coche
que utilizado más avenida aquí en los
filetes de cable que necesitan mucho y
muchas emisiones de co2
él utilizó una energía limpia en el
recibo de la luz está realmente he hecho
con energías renovables vamos a intentar
por los días es un poco de foco
segunda cuestión trabajamos y vivimos en
un entorno consumista lineal es decir
utilizado en materias primas producimos
materiales y luego nos desechamos bueno
y por qué no intentamos hacer un entorno
circular donde eso que desechamos
volvamos a realimentar lo vamos a
reutilizar lo no tenemos más plantas de
etanol y gigantes estamos construyendo
1.7 veces lo que el planeta genera cada
año es decir 0 7 veces o 07 de planetas
son consumidos de reservas y eso no se
regenera estamos destruyendo nuestro
planeta si solamente utilizaremos lo que
tuesta genera solamente podríamos vivir
hasta el 29 de julio y en españa'
dejaríamos de consumir cosas el 28 de
mayo
estamos a partir de ese día consumiendo
reservas del planeta especialmente
importante todo lo que producimos y
desechamos en cuanto a plásticos es un
enorme problema no es plástico es un
maravilloso material pero dura muchísimo
y tenemos que manejarlos y gestionarlos
muy bien para que no acaben en la
antártida con los pingüinos de hacerlo
especialmente importante en los micro
plásticos que ya están siendo
incorporados en los animales en los
peces están contaminando los peces muy
pronto vamos a tener más plástico que
peces en los mares lo cual es una
auténtica bestialidad las ciudades se
están moviendo en la declaración de 40 y
hay 23 ciudades por compromisos claros
en este sentido y qué podemos hacer
nosotros en nuestros primeros pasos
bueno
fundamentalmente otra vez tres erres
reducir la cantidad de materiales nuevos
y reutilizar los que ya tenemos y tener
cuidado en que lo que desechamos saber
se recicla
de acuerdo muy importante produce sobre
todo el plástico sobre todo en embalajes
de bolsas plásticos vamos a alguno de
los restaurantes que tenemos aquí en
este sitio de comida rápida la cantidad
de plástico de embalajes que estamos
utilizando que solamente hace falta
reutilizar reutilizar esta copa o
nuestra taza al trabajo y la lavamos lo
utilizamos de acuerdo intentamos
arreglar las cosas estamos acostumbrados
ya no funciona a la radio la tiro no se
puede intentar arreglar esta es que se
quedó sin pilas
o no la super este enchufar y utilizar
batería recargable he aquí un ejemplo
muy interesante podemos comprar su marca
de primer nivel sin comprar el
continente compramos el contenido ellos
reutilizan el envase los licencia ni los
que no les llegan a claro porque voy a
pagar por ese continente que encima
luego va a acabar en la ciudad va a
acabar en el océano va a acabar en la
antártida y sobre todo a reciclar tener
muy claro qué es lo que vamos a hacer
con nuestros residuos son pequeñas cosas
pero entre todos podemos hacer un gran
impacto
tercera cuestión las ciudades están
ahora mismo en una situación donde
necesitan conectar con el ciudadano han
empezado a invertir en el entorno del
smart cities fundamentalmente para
resolver problemas internos ahora están
en un momento donde están recogiendo
datos del mundo de vigentes de las cosas
para sintonizar monitorizar la ciudad
para darnos un mejor servicio y ya están
llenos y en los niños de datos datos que
no usan el 73% de los datos que tenga
ciudades no nos utilizan de acuerdo pero
tienen un problema y es que han
desconectado con los ciudadanos el final
no es un tipo que va por ahí andando y
que una vez cada cuatro años le tocamos
así en la espalda de dos o tres confiar
en mí me puede dar tu voto
y que has dicho estos cuatro años que
hemos conectado conmigo como he podido
contribuir a mejorar el ciudadano
estamos en un entorno donde las ciudades
pretenden pasar de el concepto de data
police datos datos datos al concepto de
participo de existencia y quiero poner
esos datos a funcionar para los ciudad
hacer un giro complicado en una ciudad
centrada en los datos en una ciudad
donde pongo al ciudadano en el centro y
pongo los datos necesito datos para
servir mejor a ese ciudadano de acuerdo
en ese sentido estamos acostumbrados a
que nuestra ciudad nos da cosas y
tenemos que plantearnos como dijo
justifica qué hacemos también nosotros
por nuestra ciudad y ahí podemos hacer
muchas cosas podemos contribuir con
nuestra información podemos colaborar
podemos participar podemos reportar las
cosas que están estropeadas está nuestra
opinión es muy interesante para ellos
también permitir que nuestra ciudad el
entre nuestros smartphones se comunique
con nosotros y permitir darle cierta
parte de nuestra privacidad hacer que la
ciudad tenga una oportunidad de conectar
con nosotros de ofrecernos
proactivamente servicios sabiendo toda
la información que sentí puedo
anticiparme y predecir cuál va a ser tu
siguiente servicio público y ofrecerte
lo prácticamente vamos a facilitarles un
poco la vida también a nuestros
gobernantes
y finalmente hablamos mucho de
inteligencia artificial y eso nos da
miedo estamos en una situación donde la
tecnología de interés artificial ha
llegado a la paridad con los humanos en
cuanto a los sentidos vista oído olfato
entendimiento del lenguaje bien esto
está muy bien estamos en una situación
donde todo lo que hacen entre
certificaciones porque lo ha programado
un programador vale pero vamos a ir a
los siguientes estadios donde la
inteligencia artificial va a conseguir
sistemas que tengan emociones que tengan
sentimientos que lleguen a tener
autoconciencia de sí mismo
pero siempre dirigidos dirigidos por
humanos que los han desarrollado de
acuerdo y que tienen preservar los
principios éticos
nos da mucho miedo pero el 91 por ciento
de las empresas están utilizando más
sumamente interesante oficial porque son
herramientas fundamentales para mejorar
nuestra vida y para los estándares de
vida que nos hemos marcado ya pero esto
da mucho miedo estamos en un cine
he contado más de 200 películas donde se
planteaban sociedades futuristas
históricas entornos absolutamente de
ciencia ficción donde los pasai boards
las máquinas dominaban el mundo el de
entes artificial hacía que los humanos
fueran esclavos esto es oficial
esto está haciendo mucho daño a nuestra
percepción y a nuestra confianza y la
tecnología la tecnología se puede
utilizar para bien o para mal no sabemos
hace muchos años pero la tecnología es
necesaria es un gran e inler nos permite
hacer cosas nunca es un destino que es
un acompañante nos permite gestionar el
mundo nos permite desarrollar mejor
nuestra vida vamos a confiar en la
inteligencia y vamos a confiar en que
estos desarrollos se hagan con
respetando al máximo los principios
éticos poniendo siempre la dignidad
humana por delante con transparencia con
la capacidad de poder
manejar muy bien nuestra información
permitiéndonos manejar nuestra
privacidad somos dueños de nuestra
identidad
tenemos que ser obsesivos a la hora de
preservar nuestra identidad de elegir
quién maneja nuestra identidad virtual
porque esta es no está presente en el
mundo
cuatro mensajes para acabar cuatro temas
donde podemos ayudar a nuestra ciudad
por un lado las tres sedes en cuanto a
reducir las emisiones de carbono
electrifique mos nuestra vida y
utilicemos el electricidad generada de
forma renovable de acuerdo intentemos
dejar de emitir cosas no queréis nada
dejar de fumar
daros cuenta que la atmósferas única y
el aire que tenemos aquí va por todo el
mundo la cuerda es una situación
colectiva por otro lado que la economía
circular los materiales que nos da
nuestra madre tierra como los utilizamos
como los manejamos
gustavo los nuevos materiales de
utilicemos las cosas no te vayas a
comprar haciendo una bolsa si la
necesitas oa grises que no necesitas
bolsa se compra una barra de pan para
gente que siente una bolsa cuando la
iguala lo que pasa pues yo compro
agarrando de nada que esconder' de
acuerdo hay muchas veces que que estamos
fruta abusando de los materiales que nos
da nuestra tierra
intentemos colaborar con nuestra ciudad
ser buenos ciudadanos tener los
comportamientos cívicos que cooperen
para construir y crear una mejor ciudad
seamos partícipes del desarrollo de
nuestra ciudad para hacer una ciudad
mejor más competitiva más atrayente para
el talento y finalmente confiemos en la
inteligencia artificial que son nuevos
desarrollos y son muy avanzados y
permiten llegar a nuevas puertas en el
desarrollo humano y científico a nivel
mundial es una tarea de todos como dijo
la gran humanista de jim jacobs
no podemos conseguir la mejor ciudad si
no estamos todos si no todos
contribuimos a crear esa ciudad algo que
nos permita tener una mejor vida para
todos la ciudad es un lugar de encuentro
donde los humanos se reúnen es la que
nos permite desarrollar nuestra faceta
social de acuerdo pues hagamos que sea
ese mejor lugar para beneficio en
realidad
[Música]
[Aplausos]